[Music]
we are here doing a little bit of a
Prince Harry pub crawl in honor of the
Royal Wedding Prince Harry marrying
Megan marquel and I'm here with Jose
general manager of Eclipse hi Jose tell
me what area of London were in because I
still don't have my jealousy in Sean
okay and Prince Harry used to come here
back in his youth is this true yeah he
used to come quite often
okay maybe even sat at this very table
so how does a royal just go out to a bar
Jose says Harry would show up with
security and a small group of friends I
mean he used to be always talking to
women he was a very like way known for
being a ladies man so he was always
flirty according to Jose Harry liked
cocktails made with vodka and gin and so
you have a signature shot here and what
is it called
it's good craic a baby a crack baby shot
what is in the crack baby crab we should
do is good vodka passion fruit puree
shambled which is a raspberry cured or
some champagne it's quite an amazing
drink it was originally invented here so
did Prince Harry take a crack baby shot
but Harry's getting married now these
days Jose sees him shopping or jogging
in the area not party and you guys have
come up with a drink in celebration of
Harry and Megan's wedding the melon
Sparkle tell me about the melons yes so
we have I mean I would most famously for
the last 20 years is a watermelon
martini and they were just basically
twist a little bit I have it with a gene
which is a pretty spirit of victory of
sugar and then just check it with lots
of love we're gonna blow it out and give
it a drink the melon Sparkle oh yeah
Cheers oh yes oh he is you can feel it I
love it like they love each other you
guys are really making our work day fun
okay perfect so let's do a crack baby
shot and I take this whole thing yeah I
mean you can zip it but then the whole
thing
and maybe one more for the road
hey when in London our stops are all
close to Kensington Palace where Will
and Kate live now and Harry and Megan
will live to top number two on our
Prince Harry pub crawl is bumpkin we're
not only the Prince Harry party but Will
and Kate as well
Amy Kyle and manager here at bumpkin we
are taking a look back at the places
that Harry used to go and there's a
little more single a little bit more of
a partier and we've heard that here at
bumpkin you even served him I did it was
very friendly quite outgoing very polite
everything's seasoned thank you okay so
I'm touching someone who has touched
Harry
Amy this makes you on another level when
you get that call do they call you and
say Prince Harry is coming they vote
mentioned in particular they will see a
member of the royal family then you can
use your imagination from there but and
they obviously don't want you to get
into the press so I think this is one of
the reasons they don't specifically tell
you which Royals how did you react to
the news that he was settling down and
settling down with an American actress
Megan Marco this peculiar of X G cos
Harry was known as a party animal but I
guess obviously found the love of his
life bumpkin came up with two royal
wedding weekend drinks the Harry and the
Megan this is the Harry it's a gin-based
cocktail very light and refreshing and
of course this is the Megan made with
American whisky so we're representing
our two nations here gin
British American whiskey for Megan all
right well let's cheers to Harry and
Megan and to you Amy bumpkin is really
feeling the Royal Wedding fever with
their decor so we had to get bumpkin at
bump
nice to meet you
we're just having a moment guys after a
couple crack baby shots at Harry it's a
Megan I'm a little bit done with this
pub crawl I'm not sure if I can handle
things like Harry so we're gonna call it
but head over to Z online.com where we
have so much more on Harry and Megan's
favorite spots all over London you can
get the inside scoop bang
[Music]
you